how I mean I feel this full-circle
moment yeah this is the and now comes
down to this the Oscars what do you feel
like today with Queens anyone we had
Brian May and Roger Taylor on set so to
come here tonight
and have them warm us up and give us a
few song everybody knows the words to is
gonna make this Oscars a very
unprecedented you want to hop up there
everybody's gonna find out in ten
minutes
but tell me I want to know before ten
minutes want to know then you would have
the insights to box right that's right
Rami
yeah I've signed a contract in NBA queen
and Adam Lambert are phenomenal together
I've seen them five times and I gotta
say this we're here as a small part of
telling Queens legacy and it is the
greatest honor we could have ever asked
for
and a great date night to this movie for
you not only are you coming away with
all of these
and probably an Oscar too but you're a
huge winner because you also walks away
with a relationship huh I got two apps
against one of the most talented
powerful actors I've got to work with
and she stole my heart
[Music]